both sides often I mean always lay claim
to delivering progress but from where
I'm sitting I suppose it's it's a plague
on both houses because both left and
right the morality that they present
damages women's lives and so long as we
have history books and morality lessons
written by men institutions ruled and
governed by men economic templates
written to the male experience I mean
Adam Smith is the ultimate right his
irony free declaration of man's
self-interested man while he sort of was
had his meals brought by his mother you
know basically this this is this for me
is the is the overarching issue which is
that both sides are bring a morality
that doesn't see women so on the right
we've got a system that prizes family
values conservatism based on very narrow
and quite oppressive views about what
families should be so white middle-class
heteronormative but you but from that
position you can still support and pass
laws on for example gay marriage because
it follows views on the sanctity of
marriage and a sort of emulation of
heteronormativity if you like and from
the right the more at that sort of
morality allows women to thrive when
they fall within conservative values so
I this idea of a meritocracy for example
where women can make it to be prime
minister if they're if they're just as
good as men if they try harder they can
get further and this declaration that
you know the right it does better for
women because they've had two female
prime ministers without sort of
examining the idea that two women in in
two hundred years is probably not that
much of a meritocracy but on the right
is when women fall outside of that very
narrow vision of morality that women are
punished so to child limits on touch
child tax credit a perfect example of
punishing families that don't meet
conservative values it's black and Asian
families the hardest
Runnymede trust I think yes in the
women's Budget Group sure that the
combination of cuts and changes to
universal credit would hit black women
the most leaving the five thousand
pounds worth of a year on average
now it's interesting because I think
then this strong moral attachment to
Family Values
does mean that the right can pass useful
legislation that recognizes for example
violence against women and girls
criminalizing female genital mutilation
revenge porn the bringing of the
domestic abuse bill but only because
that violence is seen as egregious to
the morality of family and as anomalous
episodes rather than as a result of
structural inequality that women
experience and that's why the
forthcoming domestic violence bill is so
slim which is a huge disappointment
coming from Teresa mais government what
is good about it is that it makes abuse
in front of children and an aggravating
factor it strengthens family law courts
but there is no funding additional
funding ring-fenced funding protected
sustainable sufficient funding for the
services run by and for women living
with and escaping from male violence and
of course the right has presided over
austerity that has made poor women even
poorer disproportionately been paid for
by women eighty six percent of it has
been paid by women now on the left of
course we have as jeremy JC was saying
yesterday the left is the party of women
left is the party of equality i disagree
fundamentally with this because the left
has a structural analysis and a morality
that is limited very much to class and
particularly in this latest incarnation
can't see any oppression that's not
Western and capitalist and that is why
in the past example men on the left of
condoned FGM as a cultural practice
because they don't see the oppression of
black and Asian women by black and Asian
men it doesn't fit into their structural
class analysis the left is obsessed with
working-class men's jobs jeremy corbyn's
to this summer the his made in britain
brexit plan that affirms his 50-year
focus on manufacturing which is frankly
a slap in the face to millions of women
who disproportionately employed in
service sector do you know what how the
Treasury classifies a woman our mother
raising two children and caring for an
elderly parent economically unproductive
economically inactive inactive and the
left doesn't have an answer to that
because it ignores the vast amount of
work unpaid and low paid care work that
women do
and I think you know we're going to talk
about morality of equality we need I
would expect labor not just to want to
nationalize everything from where we
store water to energy to Royal Mail but
actually to do something about social
care which has an 80% female workforce
and is absolutely on its knees so yeah I
mean the center-left has made some
progress particularly on representation
but in the 2015 election it was a huge
disappointment to me to see the left did
not make a case against austerity
despite it being evident at that point
that women were disproportionately
paying for it it just bargained with
itself over how much more of it we could
take
you